ever hit on the Dow the stock markets
the best it's ever been
jobs are the best they've ever been a
couple of other little factors that's so
bad we're doing great that we have a
great military and I thank you for that
and I want to thank my Earl and she's
been a friend of mine for a long time
and she's done an incredible job and she
just did me a beautiful favor keeping it
a beautiful Sikorsky plant open in the
great state of Pennsylvania some people
would say Commonwealth I'll call it both
but all I know is they're really happy
in Pennsylvania right now and we love
Pennsylvania and they've I really
appreciate what Maryland did I'm
thrilled to be back in your great state
a state that I won and we want it not so
late in the evening a little bit early
in the evening actually which is even
better we had a lot of support from your
company d'arco has been incredible we
have a lot of support here and one of
the reasons I'm here is Maryland one of
the reasons I'm here are you because we
really have had tremendous and it's a
great spirit great spirit in this
company we're here today to celebrate
the triumphant return of American
manufacturing you know what they said it
was going to be gone but it's not gone
it's really thriving and it's starting
to build up at a level that nobody
thought was possible everything we're
doing to keep the assembly lines rolling
full speed ahead that's being done and
we're doing it right we're proudly
defending a most important national
resource the American worker that's what
it is it's pretty amazing how the
American worker has just really there's
nobody like our American worker we're
glad to be joined today by secretary
Wilbur Ross where's Wilbur Wilbur Wilbur
okay
great job a friend of mine and somebody
who's very very tough and very very
smart Senator Ron Johnson Ron thank you
[Applause]
and two real fighters they fight for us
and they fight for you and they fight
like nobody representatives Glenn
Grothman and Sean Duffy Sean thank you
fellas
thank you I especially want to thank
your general manager here at deco Peter
Winkler Peter
they were showing me some of the work
they do it's beautiful it's complex and
it is real stuff that's the real deal
right Peter for 40 years the Patriots of
Deco aerospace have built and repaired
parts for airplanes jets and helicopters
and you have done it with unmatched
precision and unmatched skill really an
incredible company recently our entire
nation was inspired by the mastery of
your craftsmanship during our wonderful
Independence Day celebration on the
National Mall it's called a suit right
salute to America that was something
they weren't sure to think News they
weren't sure if people gonna show up did
they ever show up right if they ever
show up we had a tremendous it was
packed and it was raining it was through
people said that I have a tent because I
look very dry I said I wasn't dry and I
had no tent it was a rainy day but in a
way it was a beautiful day and when
those planes and helicopters flew
overhead it was something like we
haven't really seen too much lately it's
tremendous spirit and love in our
country that day the United States
Marines soared overhead in a magnificent
aircraft like the ones you support from
here in Milwaukee the mv-22 Osprey our
country also witnessed the awesome might
of the US Navy flying another plane that
you will soon support the unstoppable
stealth f-35 lightning too
[Applause]
I get to meet a lot of pilots I once
said to one of the pilots he looked like
central casting delivery Tom Cruise but
maybe better little taller and a little
stronger and I said so tell me how good
is the f-35 compared to other planes
enemy craft he said well they have a
problem they can't see it I said that
sounds good to me not knowing too much
about it that sounds good but he said
there's nothing like it now remember
there was a long time ago now toward the
beginning
in addition workers at this facility
help maintain our massive c-130 hercules
transport planes and are fearsome uh-60
Black Hawk helicopters and our f-16
Fighting Falcons
[Applause]
pretty busy what are you doing your
spare time by the way a lot of work with
the help of two hundred and eighty pound
Americans at Dirk oh and you know what I
mean the USA truly has the best aircraft
flown the best pilots and we have the
greatest pilots in the world they fly
the that they are pilots like no other
made the maiden maintain the best
workers and best workers anywhere in the
world and I'm excited to hear that
thanks to your new responsibilities for
the f-35 your company will be expanding
its workforce by 15% is that right well
[Applause]
since the election we've created more
than 6 million new jobs nobody would
have believed that during the campaign
if I would have said 6 million jobs they
would have said that's he's exaggerating
I did say like 4 million but we've got
six billion so I was under exaggerating
including more than half a million
manufacturing jobs we added two hundred
and twenty four thousand jobs last month
alone which is a tremendous number far
greater than projection last year US
manufacturers reported the highest
optimism ever recorded so folks like
Marilyn would say were the most
optimistic we've ever been would you say
that screw you better say yes Marilyn
see no sign o Maryland very well and I
know she feels that way we're now the
economic envy of the entire world when I
meet prime ministers and presidents and
kings and queens they all start off by
congratulating me on the great economy
wages are rising fast and rising fastest
for our blue-collar workers that's
exciting you hear so much about the
upper end well they don't realize the
blue-collar proportionately blue-collar
workers the manufacturing companies
these are the companies that are doing
so well unemployment has reached the
lowest rate in over half a century and
we expect to soon be beating that
you
you
hello's ever the history of our country
and right here in Wisconsin the
unemployment rate is just 2.8 percent
among the very lowest in the country
it's a great state it's a fantastic
state so
we've powered our economic turnaround by
following two fundamental rules if it
hurts American workers we don't do it
it's very simple and if it helps
American workers we definitely do it and
we do it quickly it's very simple
our agenda is pro work pro-family
pro-growth 100% pro-american it's
America first it's make America great
again and you know what now it's Keep
America great because we're doing
awfully well we're doing awfully well to
stop the offshoring you know what
offshoring is of American jobs I signed
the largest package of tax cuts and
reforms in the history of our country
since then eight hundred and seventy-six
billion dollars that's a lot even for
you Marilyn right that's the big thing
has poured back into the United States
from abroad we want companies to invest
hire build and grow right here in
America and right here in Wisconsin
[Applause]
we cut a record number of job-killing
regulations which will give the average
household an extra $3,000 each year so
each year the average household and you
all say it you all feel it will get an
average of $3,000 that's a lot that's
the biggest tax cut we've ever had in
this country and by the way I see the
Democrat platform they want to raise
your taxes I don't think that I don't
know maybe and I haven't been a
politician too long somehow that doesn't
play well right they want to raise your
taxes okay we'll figure that one out we
launched an American energy revolution
the United States is now the number one
producer of oil and natural gas anywhere
in the world and it's not even fair
[Applause]
and with a couple of environmental
approvals for certain pipelines we can
get that and really do something with
that number it'll go up very
substantially very quickly especially in
the state of Texas we're reversing
decades of economic surrender and
restoring America's industrial might we
surrendered economically what we did was
so crazy
we helped other countries that we never
thought about our own country we lost
the magic we've gotten it back and we've
gotten it back I think you'll soon see
greater than ever before
[Applause]
and your executives now those companies
are pouring back into our nation
automobile companies from Japan and
other nations are pouring back in many
many of the great auto companies are
coming back into Michigan they're coming
back into Pennsylvania Ohio Florida
North Carolina you have not so many jobs
left we have to get some more workers
over here I think Marilee we have to do
something but we have automobile
companies and other companies pouring
back in and you had the greatest year
you've ever had in the history of this
state this is a great state but you had
your best economic year that you've ever
had so that's great our nation was made
of vibrant and strong and it's got to be
the most powerful the best it really was
made with American manufacturing and you
know that a previous administration said
manufacturing done you're gonna have to
take a magic wand to bring it back well
that was wrong the previous
administration they allowed foreign
nations to plunder our wealth and to
pillage our factories they sold out our
workers and they hollowed out our Edisto
heartland but those days are over and I
have to tell you it's not just the
previous administration it's been many
administration's in all fairness to
President Obama it's been many many
administration's they allowed it to
happen they allowed our fraktur EES to
close our workers really to go to not
have jobs we created jobs for other
places for other nations and we
sacrificed so many 60,000 plants
millions and millions of jobs were lost
during I call them the stupid years but
now we're back into the really smart
years we had the smart years now with
the really smart years they were the
stupid years what they were doing was
incredible NAFTA one of the world's
worst trade deals ever I know a couple
of others we've been involved in them
too World Trade Organization that's a
beauty you don't know as much about that
but NAFTA was a disaster for this
country and we're gonna be replacing
that very soon hopefully with the u.s.
MCA and that's going to be something
really really special
it's gonna keep jobs one of the things I
said to start off I don't want people
leaving this country meaning companies I
don't want to incentivize companies to
leave fire their people build product
sell the product over in our country no
tax whatsoever so we end up with no jobs
no factories no taxes no nothing it's
not going to happen anymore and it can't
happen under our new agreement
[Applause]
and I've been talking about this subject
for twenty years it's possibly one of
the reasons I ran I used to look at
Michigan where they'd lose their car
companies one after another you lost so
many companies in Wisconsin everybody
lost Ron everybody lost companies they
were losing companies left and right and
we're not gonna have that anymore we
have an incentive now to stay in this
country we have an incentive to build
and manufacture in this country and
that's the way we want it that's the way
it's going to be it's going to be
America first
[Applause]
after years of rebuilding foreign
nations we are finally rebuilding our
nation's it's as simple as that we've
built other nations we focused on other
people's borders we'd fight for other
borders but we don't fight for our own
border we have open borders and they had
our military men protecting their
borders figure that one out but it's all
changing and it's changing very rapidly
and we're doing really well right now
Mexico has 21,000 troops on the border
guarding our border our laws are so bad
our military can't do a damn thing we
have the greatest military in the world
but between catch and release we catch
him and we release him thank you it we
catch him take a little number come back
in 3 4 years these are the Democrats and
they should change him Shawn they should
change him so easily but they don't want
to do it it's politics they want open
borders I really think they want open
borders even though four or five years
ago they all wanted strong borders and
they wanted walls and everything else
that was when they were saying but
they're no longer saying for years
politicians let China take the crown
jewels out of our country my
administration has taken the
toughest-ever stance to stop these
incredible abuses as a candidate for
president I also promise to replace the
disaster known as NAFTA since NAFTA's
adoption the United States was losing
jobs and losing plants like nobody's
ever lost before almost one in five Auto
jobs were lost due to NAFTA and I think
that's a wrong number I think it's worse
than that
but now we're demanding that you get as
people working here and as companies and
as a great great strength I want you to
have strength but I want you to have a
level playing field because when you
have a level playing field nobody can
beat you you didn't have a level playing
field you had a playing field that was
like this and you had to go up hill
that's why we're replacing NAFTA with
the brand-new US Mexico Canada agreement
the u.s. MCA will be the most modern
cutting-edge trade agreement
history with the strongest protections
for the American worker ever put in any
trade agreement and that was the single
most important thing to me the u.s. MCA
will close the biggest loopholes that
cause the mass exodus of manufacturing
under NAFTA by ratifying the u.s. MCA
Mexico is now committed to be the
toughest and have the toughest labor
provisions the highest environmental
standards and the most comprehensive
enforcement provisions ever implemented
in a trade agreement ever for years
labor unions and lawmakers urged past
administration's to secure these types
of trade provisions they did absolutely
nothing no administration did anything
except lose jobs we were laughed at by
the rest of the world we were patsies
and I didn't blame China I didn't blame
all of these countries Mexico Mexico
they took 30% of our automobile business
I don't know if you know that or not
they have plants the likes of which
you've never seen before
they took 30% probably more than that of
our automobile I don't blame them I
don't blame anybody I blame our past
leaders I blame the people in
administrations that allowed this to
happen it's not China's fault that we
were stupid it's not China's fault that
we allowed it to happen
we'll lose 500 billion dollars a year
it's now turning we're taking in
billions and billions of dollars in
tariffs I'm giving billions of dollars
back to the farmers because they
pinpointed the farmers they said we're
not going to buy here we're not going to
buy there because then Trump will stop
doing to us what he's doing except the
farmer said we don't care because he's
right because for 15 years a farmer if
you look 15 years it's been like this
it's a one-way street and it was a
street downward but it's been incredible
and I'll never forget I had a meeting
Maryland with farmers a year ago and I
told them what is going to happen and I
said you got to be the single biggest
beneficiaries ultimately and I said
we're going to get you subsidies we're
going to get and farmers looked at me
like
one time at probably thirty in a big
beautiful room the Cabinet Room at the
White House beautiful for the cabinet
but I wanted the farmers in the Cabinet
Room because I like the farmers and they
said so we don't want subsidies I said
what do you mean we don't want subsidies
we want a level playing field I said how
can you tell me nobody's ever said that
everybody's coming in here looking for
whatever they can get that we don't want
subsidy it was to this day it's never
happened before they didn't want that
they just wanted a level playing field
they'd say give us a level playing field
and nobody can beat us at what we do I
thought it was one of the most beautiful
thing but in the meantime they were
targeted by China I went to sonny Perdue
and I said Sonny how much has China
spent let's say in the in just about the
biggest year he said sixteen billion
dollars sir I said here's what I'm doing
I'm giving our farmers 16 billion
dollars out of the tariffs which frankly
are much more than that I shouldn't say
that because they'll ask for more but
they are the tariffs are far more than
that and a lot of companies are leaving
China now because they want to go to a
non-tariff country and some of those
companies are coming here it's been
incredible we're taken in billions and
billions of dollars and I'm giving our
farmers a chunk because they were
targeted these are great American
patriots and I'll tell you I didn't see
anybody you know they go and they do
these focus groups on television even on
the the real fakers on television and
what you think would be the farmers
world know it's not like things are
perfect but we're with our president but
now things are pretty good because we
are doing 16 billion and that was the
most of China ever purchased and some of
the farmers are really doing well I
think they're really certain we're over
the hump we're doing really well and in
the meantime our government has billions
of dollars of money pouring in and that
money is paid for by China through
reducing if you take a look what they're
doing is they're playing around with
their monetary policy to a level like
nobody's ever seen before we're not
paying and they're also pumping out cash
into their system and China's paying RP
not paying now other countries it's a
little bit different China's China but
they're doing things in order to make
sure that they keep those jobs in China
but they're losing a lot of companies
and some of those companies are coming
here because we get it done we know how
to get it done I know how to win we win
Maryland knows how to win this company
knows how to win the job you've done is
incredible at this company that's why
I'm glad I'm here the u.s. MCA is vital
to the future of the American automobile
industry under NAFTA foreign companies
could manufacture thousands of their
parts overseas ship them to Mexico and
Canada for assembly and send their
foreign made cars right into the United
States tax free you knew about that mr.
manager right tax free that doesn't work
too well right wouldn't you say they
should have ended that about 20 years
ago with the u.s. MCA we have declared
no more of that nonsense we're not
letting it happen seventy-five percent
of every automobile under the deal must
be made in North America and we're
requiring a large portion to be made by
high wage labor which means American
labor because you were competing against
people that frankly were slightly they
were getting slightly less money than
you do am I trying to be nice when I say
that does anybody object a area they
were getting slightly less like about
twenty percent twenty percent of what
you get the u.s. MCA is but it was
unfair to our country it was unfair to
our people it was unfair to our workers
the u.s. MCA is estimated to create
76,000 brand-new American auto jobs and
very quickly that means more cars more
trucks and auto parts will be stamped
with those beautiful words made in the
USA remember we used to see that all the
time made in the USA
[Applause]
maybe we could start stamping here we'll
start right here made in the USA people
love it people love it I remember I used
to see it all over made in the USA or
made in America but maybe we should you
know would take you about with your
geniuses here they could have that
stamped on parts in about two seconds
right he's looking he said I wonder
that's gonna cost us any money to do
this not much that much it's all part of
the whole deal but made in the USA the
u.s. MCA is also a tremendous a
tremendous victory for in particular
farmers because we have had such support
to help dairy farmers right here in
Wisconsin the u.s. MCA stops unfair
trade barriers from Canada
people love Canada I love Canada but
there were a few countries that took
advantage of us more than Canada they
were charging us as tariffs of two
hundred and ninety seven percent they
wanted to keep it under three hundred
because it sounded better two hundred
ninety seven percent nobody knew that
the farmers know that they knew it very
well because essentially what they're
doing is they're saying you can't sell
your product in Canada because the
tariff was so high you couldn't say you
couldn't sell it in Canada under our
trade agreement we will see significant
increases in exports of Wisconsin
agriculture supporting jobs throughout
the state it's going to have a
tremendous impact on your agriculture
and on your manufacturing once fully
implemented the u.s. MCA will bring up
to six hundred thousand jobs to our
shores and it's probably going to be
well over at one point two million jobs
[Applause]
and here at Darko you'll be able to
expand your commerce with Canadian
customers and suppliers and they'll be
buying your product now they have an
incentive to buy your product before
this deal they had no incentive
whatsoever to buy product in the United
States I want to personally thank
Marilyn and Lockheed Martin for
supporting this groundbreaking agreement
what you've done is really great you've
been she has been you've been calling
everybody I helped right I've heard you
have you know the wake was left there
Colin can you get her off our back
that's good that's what I want that's
why I tell Merrill see if you can do it
if you want to do it we need help from
the Democrats to get it done because
it's political season and I say it's a
bipartisan let it be a bipartisan bill I
don't want credit for it let it be a
bipartisan bill the u.s. MCA for years
members of Congress have demanded a
replacement for NAFTA now they finally
have the best replacement that they can
ever even imagine the farmers can't
believe it the manufacturers can't
believe it even Maryland the unions
can't believe it it's good for everybody
so on behalf of our nation's loyal
hard-working citizens I'm calling on
Congress to pass us MCA and send it to
my desk immediately for signature we
shouldn't be playing around and every
day that goes by it gets more and more
political because we get closer and
closer to the election and maybe it's
harder it shouldn't be hard I mean the
day before you should sign this the day
before the election but view it as a
bipartisan bill and it shows that
Congress is doing something other than
wasting time on the witch-hunt and the
nonsense that they they work so hard at
they work so hard if they worked 1/100
as hard on immigration it would be
solved at about 15 minutes just a waste
of time
[Applause]
thank you to ensure that all citizens
can thrive the modern economy as we know
it and it's really gotten modern we also
launched the pledge to America's workers
I'm thrilled that Lockheed Martin has
committed to providing apprenticeships
and workforce development opportunities
for 8,000 of our great citizens thank
you
my administration lives by a very
crucial motto a motto that you would
agree with 100% by American and hire
American those other days are gone
[Applause]
so as we restore our economy we're
really restoring our standing in the
world we're respected again America is
respected again like it hasn't been
respected in many many years we were
laughed at
we were scoffed at we were liked why
shouldn't we be liked we were a patsy
but we're respected again folks as you
know better than anyone economic
security is national security and here
at d'arco one in every five employees is
a veteran that's a great number
[Applause]
great number
and by the way Shawn stand up for a
second Shawn I want to just reciprocal
trade right he's I put him in charge I
said do me a favor
when a country charges us a hundred
percent we charge them a hundred percent
when a country charges us twenty five we
charge them twenty five when one charges
us in some cases three hundred and forty
percent we charge them three so
something's gonna happen maybe they'll
go down to zero or maybe we'll take it a
lot of money but Shawn's in charge the
reciprocal trade act of probably will
say 2019 or 2020 Cola whatever you want
it has to get done when that gets done
nobody's gonna be taken advantage of
this country any longer so I appreciate
your being on reciprocal trade out my
favorite word reciprocal it's my
favorite word reciprocal among those
with us today is Teresa spray to Trent
who began her career in the US Air Force
and the Wisconsin Air National Guard
where is she come on up here come on
in the military she supported legendary
aircraft such as the u2 and the sr-71
blackbird for the past 21 years from
right here in durka they like you by the
way tourism they really like you you
know you like them too all bad right
Teresa's continue to keep our nation's
aircraft flying I want to just thank you
you're a very special person I said I
want a couple of special people yeah we
don't have too much time just give me
one and they gave me you that's pretty
good say a few words
[Applause]
Thank You mr. president for this
opportunity when I joined the Air Force
after high school I never imagined where
this journey would take me it has been
amazing one of the many things that I
enjoy about being a part of Dirk oh and
Lockheed Martin is that I get to work
alongside the most talented people in
the aviation industry such as yourself
[Applause]
as a veteran I'm incredibly proud to
work for Lockheed Martin because I
continue to support our men and women in
uniform every day
[Applause]
Thank You mr. president for your
steadfast support of our military
[Applause]
I would also like to thank miss Houston
and my Lockheed Martin and Dirk Oh
family most importantly I would like to
thank my husband for taking this journey
with me and for his service to our
country as a military retiree
[Applause]
great job thank you thank you very much
good family
nice beautiful thank you to ensure our
service members have the tools they need
we're rebuilding the US Armed Forces
with 700 billion dollars last year and
this year 716 billion dollars that's the
highest ever and I must say the
projected budget is probably in the
neighborhood of you'll be happy about
this Maryland 730 billion maybe 733
billion dollars but you know our armed
forces were depleted they were just
depleted they were tired they were
exhausted the plains world the equipment
was o even the uniforms world and
there's no other more important job that
a president has you know they say United
States Supreme Court judges that's very
important but I think even before that
it's our military assistance so while I
like to cut budgets and all of the folks
up here in Ron we like to cut budgets we
also have to have a strong military
other words budgets don't mean too much
when you get right down to it so we
don't have a big church
[Applause]
so our commitment to our defense
industrial bases creating jobs for
Wisconsin workers in Milwaukee
Oshkosh and all across this wonderful
state from Wisconsin to Arizona
Pennsylvania to California workers such
as you are forging new tanks and ships
and submarines and beautiful American
aircraft to make our military the most
powerful anywhere in the face of the
earth
our military now is new we have new
planes we have new ships we have many
ships being built many submarines being
built
submarines like nobody's ever seen
before and other things men and women
like you make this country run you make
this country proud you make this country
great you keep our lanes of commerce
flowing our communities thriving and our
great American flag flying high the
magnificent red white and blue flies
higher
every day you're building our nation's
unlimited future and you are doing it
with American hands American hearts and
with American steel our steel companies
are coming back so strongly the dumping
is slowing down and when they do dump
they pay a very very heavy price it's
called 25 percent right into the
Treasury of the United States and our
steel companies are coming back and
they're coming back strong no one can
beat the American worker and no one can
match the might of loyal dedicated
patriotic American citizens you credible
people today and every day we will fight
for our workers we will fight for your
families we will fight for Wisconsin and
we will fight with all of our soul for
the glorious nation that we all love
together we are making America stronger
and greater than ever before and to
Maryland